good afternoon we are live now
good afternoon and welcome to this
webinar titled
guide to successful fiber business
models
this session is organized by the ftth
council europe
and we are a trade association with a
mission
to advance full fiber-based connectivity
in europe
we regroup 150 member companies
representing the full
ftth value chain from vendor to
operators
and investors our webinar series
consists of recurring online events
where experts are happy to share
insights about ftth technologies
markets and strategies
our next event will take place on july
the 13th and will detail
result of a global study undertaken by
other fiber councils
on the consequences of homeworking you
can check on our website for more
information
so before i introduce you to the
speakers
of today's webinar let me just share
some
practical information we are recording
this session
and you will have access to a link which
will bring you to the replay we will
also share with you
after this call a link to download
the white paper and access
the full guide which are presented today
all attendees are muted but you can post
questions during the session
by using the dedicated section on the
platform
so do not hesitate to ask questions our
panel
will address them at the end of the
webinar we have secured some time for
this
now without further due i would like to
introduce you to our speakers
starting with florian damas head of
policy and regulatory affairs
at nokia florian as chair
of the investor committee of the ftth
council europe
has coordinated the creation of the
guide we are releasing today
florian will be joined during the q a
session by eve blondel
managing director at t-rex and by
kim verneke relationship manager at
hamburg
commercial bank both eve and kim
have been closely associated with the
development of this content
and now florian the floor is yours
thank you vincent so first before we
start let me remind you that you may ask
questions in the questions box in the go
to webinar window or application
and we will have a q a after the
presentation of the guide
so about the aim of this of the guide we
have focused in the guide on successful
business models
that are characterized by private
financing
so their shareholders and bondholders
are typically private companies
although public financing is also an
element in some of them
we cover both fiber to the home and
fiber to the office
we identify key financial de-risking
features
of this model for example
what does it take to lower the risks for
investors
to commit early and scale up the
business
what does it take to private financiers
to say i am confident enough
to spend billions on fiber rollout to
achieve
geographic coverage we have described
european companies that are
representatives
representatives of the business models
described
in the guide we present in detail in the
report the private finances
the equity side of the shareholders
where we see a trend
from venture capitalist to
infrastructure funds
we have listed the banks and consortium
banks
providing depth to these companies
our focus is deliberately on the role of
private financiers we have mentioned
public funding
where it is a factor the titles of the
following eight models
are our own terminology an aim to
describe
key characteristics
the first model is called retail
consumer demand aggregation
this is the idea that a fiber operator
builds a company
and defines an original plan covering a
number of towns or cities
and asks people in that geography would
you like to sign up to become a customer
of mine
fiber network and make an upfront
commitment as a retail customer
but before they talk to the municipal
authorities and seek to have the
necessary permits
for a very fast rollout which will be
kicked off
once the commitment has been reached the
example company for model one
is named dutch class phasor in germany
their threshold is a figure of 40
percent of customers
who sign up front before building a
network
in about 85 percent of small
municipalities
there is a sufficient number of
customers who agree
to sign up for a contract of 24 months
and on the basis that local authorities
provide the necessary permits
networks are built out and the services
are delivered
on the retail market
the company has also a wholesale
activity like all the other
representative companies we present in
the guide
dutch class fazer is becoming a big
company
it is building over 6 million fiber to
the home
connections in germany has raised 7
billions
of euros of private capital to do so
and has secured 1 billion in public
funds
we focus on model one on the retail side
as a key characteristic
model two is the wholesale anchor tenant
model
a company decides to build fiber
networks
typically in secondary cities and tries
to find a couple of wholesale customers
to make a commitment to guarantee once
the network is built
to take wholesale services the example
we have given here is city fiber
which is covering 60 cities in uk and
has secured vodafone which is a major
fixed and mobile operator to make a
long-term commitment
to take up 20 percent of the lines of
their network
at the same time city fiber brought in
top talk
as a second wholesale 5.0 to the home
access customer
taking the total ftth rollout plan to 8
million homes passed by 2025.
this also entails cd fiber moving more
broadly to an open wholesale model
without hard exclusivity agreements
also in 2020 city fibers signed a
long-term deal with the mobile network
operator 3 for dac fiber
for the purposes of backhoe and a
possible extension to small sail backhoe
as of march 2021 city fiber has
14 wholesale access takers signed up
the third model is the pure wholesale
only model and the representative
company is open fiber in italy
it is a company which decides to roll
out fiber in many cities
major and secondary ones throughout the
country
it basically says we are open to
wholesaling to any broadband company
on the consumer and business markets
including
connecting data centers any mobile
backhoe
etc it lays down the plan and it secures
these customers on a clear commitment
that it will stay as a wholesale company
and will not compete with them
on the retail market it tries to attract
a wide portfolio of wholesale customers
and in some cases
even the incumbent operator to some
extent
there is a lot more going on in italy
but that is the start
the part sorry we wanted to present in
relation to this model
in this report we also talk about the
ultra rural areas so-called white areas
where open fiber was the winner of
tenders to serve those areas
mod 4 focuses on meeting high quality
and high reliability demand
this is not only about fiber to the
business but also fiber to the office
fiber to the hospitals fiber to the
universities
and fiber to data centers it also covers
connecting wholesale access points
like base stations and interconnection
points
the representative company is eurofiber
it is the oldest company we have
interviewed in this guide which is 22
years old
it has two key mobile operator customers
in the leather lens
other three it has built a selective
network
mainly in urban and metropolitan areas
in business parks where there is a
demand for high capacity
and reliability connections up to one
terabit per second
it serves both retail and wholesale
markets
eurofiber is also significant as it has
internationalized it has presence in
multiple countries in europe
reliance on public funds is typically
non-existent
or very low given that the market
addressed
is willing and able to pay for the for
the specific type of fiber connections
delivered
on commercial terms
model 5 is the vertically integrated
incumbent telco
such as altis in portugal the incumbent
telco
was taken over by another investor altis
europe in 2015.
altis portugal is notable for initiating
a rapid and large-scale copper to fiber
transition
its decision to invest in fiber and to
roll it out rapidly
and ubiquitously was triggered by a
requirement placed
upon upon it to spin off its hybrid
fiber coax network in 2007
it has achieved now well over 90 percent
of the lines
which have become fiber its copper
shutdown is really close
on the horizon as its full national
coverage
significantly the company has sold off
50
minus one share of its fiber network two
financial investors
in the form of a private equity fund
which will come back which we will come
back to
model 6 refers to the minority
co-financing model
we focused on the operator free in
france
which has more than 20 percent of the
fixed broadband market
and 27 of the ftth retail customers
it's a major fixed and mobile broadband
player on the french market
we describe in the guide what it has
done
it has built its own fiber network in
limited areas
but it comes in as the minority
co-financer
of third-party networks in particular
the network of orange friends but also
the networks of concession holders
which we will describe in the next model
basically it buys portions of 5
10 15 or 20 percent but very often 20
percent
where it basically says i will give you
20
of the money you need to lay down the
fiber network
if in exchange you give me in the
feasible rights of use
what we call irus for 40 years
to do whatever i want with a fiber
network to serve any types of customers
and any other activities this model is
influenced by the french government
policies and regulation
model 7 is the concession by public
authority
it's the model which exists in multiple
countries
such as france and sweden here we
describe mainly the french model
with the representative company altitude
and rasultru
the french government has split the
territory in different areas
where they think the commercial market
will take care of itself
and fiber will be rolled out areas
where it is clear there will be no
business driven development
where there is no prospect for a private
investor
or multiple networks to be rolled out
they have followed the local and
regional authorities to issue
exclusive concessions to try to attract
somebody to build a fiber
to the home network and fiber to
everything
in particular geographic areas what has
emerged over the years
is the number of companies that are
specialized in becoming builders
of these concession networks altitude
infrastructure being one of them
they have become big companies under
this model
in the early years of development of the
concession model in france
local and regional authorities typically
provided significant amounts of public
funding
to concession holders under the system
in which the bidder
demanding the lowest public subsidy wins
the concession
since 2019 given that strong competition
has emerged from well-established
private companies such as action
altitude infrastructure tdf xp fiber
as well as orange friends to win
concessions
the winning bids are for zero public
subsidy
model has become so successful and
stable
that networks can be built without
public subsidy
that is an important learning point for
other countries as well
the last model described in the guide is
model 8
represented by iner in poland which
focuses
on ultra rural areas where it is the
only provider
it identifies large clusters of very
rural areas
typically small villages and low density
areas with scattered population
where availability of fixed broadband is
limited
for example where copper loop length are
too long to provide any broadband
connectivity
or to support higher speeds xdsl
variants
or where there is no hybrid fiber coax
network
this corresponds to what is often
referred to as
white areas where the business case for
ftth may be difficult
it focuses on the retail and the
wholesale markets
via separate divisions it builds a ftth
access network
to serve rural and remote areas
accompanied by
a backbone network in order to bring
traffic to aggregation points
in the capital city and perhaps a few
other cities
this is essential to attract wholesale
customers which would otherwise have
limited ability
and an interest in serving rural and
remote areas
and eases their decision to take
wholesale access
it also avoids a situation in which
other operators overbuild the backbone
segment
that is the line of the eight stylized
business models and their
representative companies now the
presentation will focus on the
conclusions of the report
and the list the lessons we can learn
from studying
these models but before we dive into the
conclusions
just to share with you the content
of the guide for each of the eight
business
models um the stylized description
contains
the geographic area and scope
market positioning in terms of uh
is it retail wholesale markets does it
include other types of markets like
mobile buckle
there will be also key financial
de-risking features
such as securing retail and or wholesale
upfront contract commitments
we also provide information about
capital and financing
and we list a simple european company
corresponding to each specific business
model
we provide geographic geography and
metrics
the company history the services they
deliver
the type of network architecture and
their choices
in terms of technology over fiber and in
some cases
where it makes sense the role of
national regulations
we also provide profile of private
financiers
now let's come to the conclusions
the companies we present are finance
build-out machines which secure their
financing to build out more
each company is doing it on a very large
scale
at a rapid pace they are clustering
projects
in geographic areas it is not like they
focus on an area
and then expand what we see are
companies selecting areas
such as cities villages towns
and putting them together in a single
business project
it is not necessarily the case to go for
homogeneous
areas for build-outs if we take together
the eight companies of this guide we see
they are already about
20 million five per to the homes
past and if we include minority
co-financing which is the operator free
in france
the figure is over 4d 40 million homes
fast
all of these companies have tangible
plans funding fully in place from their
shareholders
and from their adapters to reach over 45
million homes by n2025
which could go up to 75 million
if we add the minority co-financing
there as well
even in the meantime these plans are
still being accelerated
and we may expect higher numbers at the
end of 2025
compared to what is presented here
because of further boosters
because our further boosters are being
put on demand
what we see is that private financing
models have become the norm
for urban areas but also rural areas
this is a strong conclusion that we are
reaching is that
private financing is fundamental
and that we are no longer in a
perspective where public funding
is absolutely needed for deploying fiber
in less dense areas
we also see that private equity
infrastructure funds
meaning financial institutions which are
specialized in funding
other infrastructures such as railways
ports tall roads hospitals
and other very long-term business plans
with guaranteed
recurring revenues are moving in the
fiber business
as they have understood that it is a
stable business
with long-term returns and clear
predictability
all this means that the market has been
considerably
de-risked the money that these private
equity funds
which is in part their own money but
actually to a very large proportion
pension funds from third-party
organizations
are investing in those private equity
funds and
invest many billions in fiber projects
we also see banks providing large
amounts of debt
via loans bonds etc directly
but most often through consortia and we
have listed them in the guide
we see several cases where there's more
than 10 banks and in one case more than
15 banks which come together and put
several billions
and in one case more than 4 billion euro
to provide
funding of a very ambitious fiber
project in italy
with open fiber these banks are either
global or regional
which take a real interest in the
geography where it's happening
therefore we see consortia coming
together with different bank profiles
on the keys to financial de-risking we
have listed three
of them which are straight to the point
the first one
is upfront contractual commitments
the second one is exclusive concessions
awarded by tenders by public authorities
and the third one is the role of getting
wholesale customers
the upfront commitments commitment can
be at the retail demand
at aggregation level the network is only
built
at a certain proportion of customers
which will sign to commit
we have put here minimum 30 percent as
it has been the threshold
used by certain companies in certain
countries we have interviewed
some companies such as dutch class visor
have even higher thresholds
the 30 figure is more as the stylized
business model
the wholesale and co-tenant of city
fiber
where they attracted vodafone and mobile
operators
upfront for long-term contracts signing
also customers for long term contributes
to de-risking the project
it is also trending to open fiber
networks to wholesale
and then we have minority co-financing
where somebody takes the initiative
and another operator will add another 20
of money
up which corresponds more or less to its
market share
this allows to de-risk the project for
both operators
we see exclusive concessions for example
in france
portugal and sweden where the subsidies
are decreasing
as the market is getting mature
we see that four out of eight models are
trending towards wholesale
as their primary or sole activity
now a few words on density area and the
colors that you see on the slide are
there to explain
and to highlight the countries
many of the businesses we have profiled
have reached
a level of predictability because they
have the scale
and the quasi-assured revenues for the
long run
and indeed in some cases real
contractually assured revenues
this enables also the low density areas
to be built out
and is happening based on private fund
let's highlight our examples model one
in germany with the retail demand
aggregation
we see that wholesale has become more
important on that model
and that it is focused on smaller towns
and villages in germany
it represents many billions of
investment and received one billion of
public funding
with a successful focus not on cities
but towns
model one is overwhelmingly based on
private funds
we see in model 5 the portuguese model
where the incumbent is deploying fiber
in the whole country
and there is a few other wholesale
companies focused which are completing
the nationwide coverage
based on the tender system which
occurred in the past
about models six and seven which are
french models
minority co-financing and concessions
they are
really pushing now to cover rural areas
at the end of 2025 we will have de facto
nationwide fiber coverage
based on the combination of french
models
the point about public funding trending
to zero is the case in portugal
and france the public funds remain
important levers
in mother one the dutch classifies in
germany
in mother 3 with in italy with open
fiber where the italian government
issues tenders
for covering the so-called white areas
and the wholesale company open fiber was
able to win
all of those tenders notably because it
was focused on the wholesale market
which would maintain a level of
competition on the service layer
in those areas in
model eight in-air the company we have
profiled
received about eighty-five percent of
its capex to build out those fiber
networks
and receive public funding for the build
of the backhoe to the cities
so operators can get access there
nationwide coverage
is within reach now of countries like
portugal and france
for the end of 2025. for other countries
like germany uk or belgium
they are still behind
now about the clear commonalities
between all these business models
securing solid recurring revenue streams
is key to attracting
investors it is the model of discounted
cash
cash flow that is how you finance a
company
when you know that over time it will
have enough money to cover its
investment
and that it will be on the path to clear
profitability
on the retail demand aggregation and
upfront retail contracts
just to say that on model 4 which is the
focus on high quality and high
reliability demand
eurofiber is focused on the business to
business market
and even on model 1 touch class visor
since it acquired in xio
shows an increased interest in wholesale
getting major wholesale customers and
even getting all the wholesale customers
is prevalent in all the models listed in
the guide
except for model 5 which is the
vertically integrated model represented
by altis in portugal
everybody is focusing on wholesale and
trying to make sure to get as many as
possible and hopefully all the wholesale
customers
are really trying really hard to have
the incoming telco as part of their
customers
mobile backup and data centers are
always kind of the part of the plan as
well
it is clear that open fiber in italy
touch cut pfizer in germany and city
fiber in uk
are enablers of the transition from
copper to fiber
various incentives are actually in place
to make the transition smooth and fast
for the fiber companies to have a quick
path to profitability
and expansion of their networks
having a pre-existing important position
on retail markets
so being a big isp or a big broadband
private a
big broadband provider is obviously
important as well
in terms of having recurring revenue
streams
that is the case when you are the
incumbent
like altis in portugal when you are the
operator free in france when you have
about 20
of fixed and mobile markets
let's look at the second set of
commonalities
fiber to everything outlined by altius
in portugal
where the commitment is very clear from
them since 2007 to build a fiber network
not just for consumer but then
but to make sure you can serve all kinds
of businesses and public administrations
that you are able to go to the data
centers that you connect over 95 percent
of lt space stations of its mobile
network
and that you are ready for next
generations of technologies
such as 5g to connect all the mobile
sales
nearly all of our companies except
eurofiber
have built going to multi-point
architecture
in a way that they can also deliver
point-to-point connections
with the necessary feeder capacity in
the network to serve
other kinds of needs including data
centers
and high-end business customers such
fiber architecture
takes everything into account to deploy
fiber to everything
all models aim to reach customer
centricity
and excellence what we have seen
historically
is that the incumbent telco was required
by regulation to give wholesale access
to its copper network
to its competitors it did not like that
so it did not provide really great
services and tried to deny or refuse or
sometimes even degraded the experience
so the relationship between the
incumbent telco and its competitors
is typically not a very good one we see
the fiber companies have been able to
come on the market by providing faster
speeds
than xdsl and hybrid fiber coax networks
and superior quality meeting latent or
explicit needs
of retail and wholesale customers
they also have a non-adversarial
relationship
with wholesale customers in other words
ensuring clarity that the provider will
not compete
on retail markets in some cases
contractually guaranteed explicit
non-discrimination of wholesale
customers where the provider is present
on both retail and wholesale markets is
offered
one commonality is avoiding or averting
local access network competition
where possible by avoiding build out in
areas already served by hybrid fiber
coax networks
and by granting wholesale access on
attractive terms to avoid that the new
fiber networks are overbuilt
by the telecom incumbent or by others
another commonality is offering
co-financing by minority investors
and or entering into minority
co-financing deals
represented by models six and seven and
a cell of proportion of the fiber
infrastructure
or of a stake in a special purpose
company to infrastructure
investors under model five and six
now the invention the ambition and the
ability to scale up and industrialize to
become a building machine
is essential for securing private
long-term investors specifically
clustering
smaller smaller projects
meaning fiber bills in many tens or
hundreds of villages
or multiple cities and cities city areas
into one or multiple bankable projects
worth tens
or hundreds of millions of euros or even
billions
is what has driven the success of the
companies profiled in this guide
we see the clustering of multiple types
of geographical areas that have similar
characteristics
but we don't see one homogeneous
geographic area today
perhaps we could see at a later stage
market consolidation with merger and
acquisitions but for now what prevails
is homogeneity
of geotypes rather than homogeneity of
territories
and then we see in two cases altis in
portugal and three in france
which have actually sold a fiber company
that they created
in part two specialized fiber investors
haltis sold half of the share minus one
share
and three sold everything plus
well half of the shares plus one share
the one has the minority the other one
has the majority at the end
and each raised over a billion of euro
from making those sales
this model is similar to what is
happening in the mobile space
where companies like cellnex and
american towers
and others are buying the mobile maps
of the mobile operators because they are
better at running this infrastructure
and attracting other operators
we will not be surprised to see other
fiber companies following this path
by creating specialized fiber companies
that are obviously wholesale only
and are committed to operate a network
separately from any retail market
which are attractive to financial
investors which clearly see the path on
return
without any destruction it also helps
retail companies to deliver
itself from paying some depths by the
money they get
they got from selling their fiber assets
and perhaps use that money for further
expansion
this is the last slide on commonalities
we will now focus on some specific
points
some models described appear to be
converging with one another over time
for instance the wholesale anchor tenant
approach
whereby a strong upfront commitment is
made
is made by one or a few wholesale access
takers
is and remains highly relevant but one
successful
it trends towards a more regular
wholesale only model
where a wide range of wholesale access
takers is actively pursued
city fiber which represents model 2 as
open to another customers
to other customers in the wholesale
front and has
renegotiated its exclusive deals with
anchor tenants
to become a wholesale provider to
anybody
business models are both refining and
developing over time
with some models increasing in relevance
as they are more widely adopted and
financed to enable massive scale
under model one dutch class visor is
widening its b2b business and wholesale
activities
under model 4 over the years
eurofiber acquired companies in the
netherlands belgium and france
such as the dutch regional business
fiber networks
the belgian railroads fiber network data
centers
and data center connectivity companies
in france
two announcements occurred after we did
the interview
one is an agreement with proximus in
belgium for fiber to dome
another is the establishment with
winterfell of a berlin-based joint
venture
to provide fiber to the home and fiber
to the office
the rules of the national governments
the national regulatory authorities
and municipal rules for rights of way
are often very important
in some countries notably france and
poland as represented
in models six seven and eight policies
and regulations
are a driver for specificities of the
business models that are described
example minority co-financing concession
models
scope of state support this can lead to
a specific set of circumstances
that is not readily replicable in other
countries
merger and acquisition activity is
occurring in the fiber infrastructure
sector
and is likely to continue a pace with
clear consequences
for business models and the compass and
the companies pursuing them
what makes the most sense at the moment
is in-country consolidation
we see the euro fiber expanding outside
of its country
now deploying networks in three other
countries perhaps
the m a will also change we are at a
stage where private equity companies are
buying and consolidating
but it could be in a few year time large
entities
that will be quoted on the stock market
and will be operating
in multiple countries fiber companies
are basically today
national or even sub-national but
already
their investors are global we see
american
swiss and australian funds investing in
the european companies
we see consortia of banks from one
country investing in other countries
we see a lot of diversity at the
investor level
one open question is will fiber
companies in europe
become multi-country and multinational
so this is the end of the presentation
and we will now switch to the
q a yeah thank you florian maybe before
we
we start the q a i've got a couple of
slides to go through
which would give you an extra minute to
to ask
and write down question in the dedicated
box on on the platform
um so thank you florian most of the
content of
uh the presentation florian just went
through is available within the white
paper
which will be sent to you after this
after this presentation so that's a
heads up
uh you will receive as a follow-up email
access to to this white paper
and if you can move to the next slide
florio uh
we have also we've also been referring
to the full guide
and and the full guide is actually a 70
pages
long detail description
uh corresponding to the in-depth study
uh which has been um developed
uh to prepare this uh this presentation
today
um so the full guide will be made
available to all
ftth council europe member and
will be sold to non-members so for any
any information
any interest in the full guide please
email us
we will take your request
an automated online um
purchasing process will be made
available in a matter of days
so with that i will move to to the q a
we already have a few questions
coming in and i will ask the panelists
to to join me so the discussion can
can start around around this question i
will probably start a gentleman with a
question
coming from portugal
but i guess many many people will have
the same
there are eight business models and joao
is asking
us why did you focus only on altis i
guess he refers to altis portugal
and not on the other very interesting
operator
uh in that country so i guess maybe a
a word on on how you selected the eighth
model
the eighth company and why
do we limit ourselves to eight
thank you i will address that uh yes we
are well aware
of fibro global and of tst
in portugal and in fact they are
mentioned in the full guide
including dst's recent capital race
um there was also a representative of
that company in our panel in the
previous conference but so
we are aware of it it is not one of the
eight models
i think basically we have focused on
models that were achieving
very very large scale and that had
a certain level of um
well let's say scalability indeed so we
were looking at models that are
running in the you know many millions of
lines and
in some cases more than 10 million lines
so our focus was on very large
projects we are fully clear on the fact
that there exists many more than eight
models and i think we could easily
uh double that number with some effort
so there are many more interesting cases
and we do think the portuguese
concession
[Music]
type models that that were subject to
public tenders about 10 years ago or a
bit more even
are really interesting and successful
models and they also reflect the fact
that public subsidy
was required initially but is no longer
required today
even to expand to less dense areas
okay thank you eve
i think it was useful clarification um
question from cornelius um
you mentioned that increasingly private
funding
is really uh is covering any any kind of
ftt edge deployment
case but are they areas and which one
where
public subsidies are
are more effective than private
investment or
critical as opposed to to private
investment
do you have specific example in mind
i think i can take that as well but kim
or florian if you want to come in so our
model 8 describes a situation that is
ultra rule
where it is clear that state aid has
been necessary
and will remain necessary for expansion
to areas where otherwise it is simply
unrealistic
for a commercial company with a private
financier to act in that area
but let me emphasize that the company
that receives the state aid in
poland india the one that we profiled
is a private company it has
as its investor an infrastructure
fund with a clear track record in
investing in other long-term
infrastructure
and it is that private company that
receives the state aid because it is
necessary in that
area to expand the area so
this is not the same as the state doing
it itself or a municipal network
choosing to invest on its own with
public money
and i can speak for myself here but
personally i believe that if you want to
achieve
rapid coverage and economies of skill
necessary
to reach a large-scale rollout that
giving the money to experienced
entrepreneurs
that know how to scale a company and
that are backed by a private equity fund
or by venture capitalists
is really a way of getting things done
on a large scale and i think that's very
important in terms of the lessons from
the guide
okay maybe a question to kim and maybe
kim you can comment on what
eva's just said as well but i have a
question
saying okay why is germany
apparently lagging behind portugal or
france i guess the the question relates
more to
uh the coverage of ftth um but
that's what i would like to you to react
to
yeah sure um i mean um
there's there's a different framework um
in portugal present with uh the first
copper shutdown
which uh is not yet uh
envisaged in germany so and as well
the dutch telecom which is uh state
owned partially
um has received a lot of the state funds
um until three years ago for their fttc
survivor to the curb build out and
decide that in the shadow of that um
that glassware was very successful
building out and they now have a
successful
buildup machine that is able to use its
scale
and this leveraging private
money in order to
get a good paced roll on there
so i think this is one of
many points that lead to
having different frameworks
for the starting points and basically
losing years
while um funding the wrong
model now speaking about fttc
uh compared to other countries like
portugal who said yeah look
it's only going to be a matter of use
when fiber is the king
okay makes sense and maybe another
question for you kim uh
coming from yusuf asking
is there a minimum transaction size
for financing ftth project
so you come from a bank any any idea of
a threshold which start to make
investment uh relevant
i would say that it's like no real
minimum it really depends on
uh how big you want to be um if you're
having a startup
and they have good management in place
and
a good equity portion in place then
maybe local saving banks
are going to be able to provide small
loans
in order to facilitate um their first
project
and and by by growing um you can end up
in
wanting to capture more equity from
experienced investors
such as bc funds or maybe pe funds and
later on infrastructure funds
and alongside the life cycle of the
companies
you will also end up asking banks and
so there are multilateral
investment banks um who are able to
arrange large financings with consortium
of banks
so i i would really say that it's like
no bare minimum
um it really depends on
how big you want to uh you want to be
so have a brave plan makes sense uh
thanks very much kim question about the
belgium
market maybe to florian or eve
um can you please elaborate say
speaker uh on the belgium situation in
which proximus is now rolling out fiber
in specific cities
will this be on enough or shall
municipalities cities or more private
initiatives
you know spontaneously develop their own
network in addition to the incumbent's
activity
anyone for real
[Music]
okay i'll i'll take the question um
it's clear that proximus has made an
announcement of a plan
um the exact geographic scope
of that plan except the end of the plan
which is many many years away
is not so well known so i think there
are
some questions in my mind personally as
to where
things will happen and in what sequence
and at what time
which could leave the opportunity open
for another entity or a public entity to
roll out
the the network but obviously it's
absolutely essential for any such
entity thinking of a plan to be aware
of whether and when proxima's the
incumbent telco
intends to cover that area with its own
network
and whether that's next year or in three
years or in nine years
if you're going to be in a situation
with a public network
that might then find itself over built
by a private network
i think you may end up in a difficult
situation knowing also that belgium is
basically fully covered by hybrid fiber
coax networks
so you would find yourself in a
constellation with three networks
we also know that the market shares at
the retail level
of proxima's plus the cable companies is
around 90
so um if those two companies are present
in the same geography
and you're the guy building the separate
fiber network
i think that sounds pretty risky to me
okay i understand thanks eves um
i've got a a nice comment from hubertus
he is asking two questions um have you
looked
outside of eu country maybe i can take
this one
no we haven't it doesn't mean that it
wouldn't bring some interest
at the ftth council uh the committee
investor committee in charge of this
study uh is open to to suggestion and
that might be something we consider in
the future
as part of the the action plan of this
committee
now if i address the second question and
bring that to you
do you see the interest or need to push
for or encourage uh pan
european ftth player with the idea that
big is is beautiful big is more powerful
more efficient
is there a scale effect
for ftth models
i think i'll start and pass on to kim
as we've explained it as florian
presented
today the market is sub-national or
national
for fiber networks it is not
naturally obvious that scaling beyond
national borders
has a particular synergy or a particular
advantage
so i think it would be more a financial
transaction that would put
multiple companies together in the same
entity
but i don't think that there is a clear
necessity
or or logical driver for a single
champion to be the fiber network
everywhere
and by the way in the incumbent telco
space we've been talking about
consolidation or potential trans-border
mergers
for many many years that has happened to
a
limited but not insignificant extent but
attempts at that or desires to do that
have clearly not come to fruition and
you will find
plenty of financial analyst reports that
say
cross-border acquisitions are probably
not the wisest way
to spend your capital at this time
kim yeah i'll follow on um
i think the question here is rather
the fiber to the home is
the right one to be pan european
because um we already have uh
companies that are active globally such
as
scio or centurylink and
others there who are providing dark
fiber or white flank services
um for the more local
or regular um regional ice piece enabled
to
being able to deliver fiber to the home
and in addition to that it's probably
hard for some
of the investors to tackle
multiple regulatory frameworks and
different revenue schemes and customer
contracts as long as they're not
harmonized across europe
and account for the different recurring
values of those cash flows
provided by this pan-european fiber to
the home
company then okay thank you
yes please um i will take another angle
to answer that question i mean
this a change of paradigm you know with
with fiber technologies
which are coming to the market we see
already operators competing with
xg spawn which is 10 gig symmetrical
nokia has announced 25 gig symmetrical
pawn as well and in the standards you
see
all the features required actually to
ensure
synchronization to now this time
use fiber access networks to connect 5g
cells
and we see that through the different
business models in the guided so there's
an appetite for this
and what i see is the interest of the
european commission actually to
for cross-border networks specifically
for
5g mobile networks but since actually
5g could now be and in 5g cells could be
connected
from from fiber access networks
maybe that could you know trigger in the
future
more than european networks deployed
over fiber
thank you froyo question from
jan about overbuilding about
uh competition on infrastructure
between uh parallel infrastructure
um the question is what is the level of
overbuilt in europe
and taking the example of the uk
is wondering whether having three or
more
fttp networks in some area
does it really make sense uh to to hover
build uh
areas so what what is uh how does it
relate to the different business model
and
what are your comments on on this
question
i think we have seen very clearly and
this was expressed in florian's
presentation
that the operators are actively avoiding
over builds
because that deeply deeply would affect
their payback time and their even their
potential
for profitability at all so measures are
taken
one to pick an area where you'll be the
first
and hopefully the only one and secondly
then attracting the other companies with
attractive wholesale terms
to avoid that they decide to over build
now we are aware that there are areas
with
multiple fiber networks they exist and i
think
they exist in a reasonably stable
fashion even in some locations
but i think we're at least at the stage
in the market development
where many developers are looking for an
exclusive position
and obviously financial investors such
as private equity funds
understand very well the value of having
such an exclusive position
while at the same time facilitating the
services of others
over those networks
and i think in the uk indeed there is
this
phase of the market where we could
come into a situation of overbuild but
i believe we're still in a situation
where the jury is out
on whether there will be more than two
fiber networks in many locations in the
uk
okay i have several questions from
rudolph so i want to to take one of
these
rodolf is asking many questions putting
in parallel a mobile network
versus fixed ftth networks
um and the relative benefits of the two
to lm2 type of access network in terms
of sustainability i don't think
sustainability is
really the topic of today nevertheless
may i take that opportunity to ask you
whether in the different model did you
see
any uh differences in the way
ftth network are leveraging uh
relation with mobile operator and fiber
back calling
as an opportunity for for the business
model and and how
is ftth network intertwined
with mobile operator strategy for the
back cooling of their
fiber and of their 5g antennas for
example
maybe florian you can take that one
um
well we see that there's more and more
interest uh
for the business models we have
described to go towards wholesale
and old selling is not about providing
you know
connectivity for residential um or
business customers
but fiber has the potential to do much
more than that
um and and we see already um
operators uh where all sellers
to use that you know but what what fiber
can bring
to to you to for other um for delivering
other services
so one one is back home for sure
we see that with with the deployment of
5g
we will deploy many more sales
we will have to connect uh sales from
from street furnitures
as well and the question is you know
what can we do should we have one fiber
for each cell
or do how can we find ways of of
actually
connecting all these cells and lower the
cost
so the question is now should we have a
you know we come from the world where we
had separate infrastructures
one for voice one for data whereas now
with with fiber
um it's not only what we used to see
like triple play or quad play but now
the opportunity as well
to connect um customers for
the the iot sector um to connect
mobile networks as well so there's a lot
of uh potential
and optimization uh to be done
thank you frank i think i'll take um
take it from there
um we are getting to the to the end of
our session
i would like to thanks um all
participants and especially all those
who ask question
i'm really sorry we cannot address all
of them there are still
a dozen of them waiting to to be
addressed
but i would definitely invite you to
download
the white paper to to get access
to the full ebook you can also contact
us at the ftth council this
document is not the end of our
contribution
to the ftth community and investor
community we will keep on
uh developing content trying to bring
value
to entrepreneurs to operators as well as
investors
looking at how we best facilitate the
rollout of fiber
and its financing so thank you very much
and with that i wish you a very good end
of your day thank you
thanks bye